alex trebek passed away on sunday ten
days
after he shot what ended up being his
final episode of jeopardy
new episodes with alex will still run
through december 25th christmas day
but for the first episode uh back since
alex's death last night
the show started like this
[Music]
i'm mike richards the executive producer
of jeopardy
over the weekend we lost our beloved
host alex trebek
this is an enormous loss for our staff
and crew for his family
and for his millions of fans
he loved this show and everything it
stood for
in fact he taped his final episodes
less than two weeks ago
he will forever be an inspiration for
his constant desire to learn
his kindness and for his love of his
family
we will air his final 35
episodes as they were shot that's what
he wanted
on behalf of everyone here at jeopardy
thank you for everything alex this
is jeopardy
[Music]
thank you ladies and gentlemen as you
can see we are still in our covet 19
protective mode it's been going well for
us so far and we want to keep everyone
safe so we will continue
in that way manish and ben welcome
aboard good luck here we go into the
jeopardy round
alice is so sad yeah klutz says
heartfelt mr sansan
for his uh passing yeah faces i heard
his last episodes will be airing on
christmas week so sad
let's hope they bring on uh someone good
yeah yeah i mean jeffy will probably
continue in some capacity but
yeah i was saying yesterday just the
idea that alex trebek still taped
episodes october 29th 10 days before he
passed away and just goes
along with the whole story of aleister
back how professional he's been
and still being that host for everyone
through this whole process but yeah roz
what were your thoughts in passing away
i know we've talked about alex before
yeah incredibly sad i mean he was
he's such a unique individual in show
business because he was
so smart but yet he was so calming and
you know oftentimes like his ability to
roast contestants was incredible like he
just had this thing that
nobody else has and even during his
entire battle you always got the sense
that
you know alex wanted to make sure that
we were
okay with what he was going through the
way that he sort of talked everybody
through it
and that only made you love him even
more and it made it all the more
that it made it all the more
heartbreaking was that there was this
sort of sense of
protection and comfort that he wanted to
put on us
as opposed to asking that from you know
all of us and uh and this
is this is tough this is like this is
he's an irreplaceable individual
oh my gosh i totally agree he's a life
staple
he's an icon he's a legend um
i just i still i can't wrap my brain
around the idea that he's gone it's just
so crazy to me i don't
really know tv without him truly like
that's
it's just him he's always been on tv um
and he is totally calming and so smart
and
and consistent he's one of the most
consistent tv personalities
i've ever really seen i mean he is every
episode he just doesn't miss a beat no
matter
what he's going through in his life um
so he's totally inspirational in that
way
it's gonna be very difficult to find
someone to do that show i i'm hoping we
don't lose jeopardy because there's so
many people
who live for that show um and learn so
much it's such a good
such a good program so yeah this is
really sad
yeah i don't think we'll lose jeopardy
either and i think alex kind of hinted
at that too in his
final interviews over those last few
months yeah he wants jeopardy to
continue as well
i like tia's comment uh she says he was
a true arbiter of truth but never made
anyone feel anything less than smart
anything less than those who could
achieve more and more yeah just the
absolute perfect host so
it's a huge loss but like i said
yesterday i mean what an amazing life 80
years old
loved his job loved his family he did so
much great in the world so yeah i mean
you can't ask more and that's what he
said in his final interview too i mean
he's had a great life and yeah it's
amazing that he got to share his life
with us too
yeah yeah and that's and what do you
think of the names being thrown around
so far because i know that they brought
ken jenning and ken jennings in a
producer role
uh to sort of get him used to that
environment and george stephanopoulos i
was reading about that today
what are your thoughts on who could be
that person that
could be all of those things because
it's difficult for me to think of
anybody
maybe anderson cooper has both sides he
has that
you know super smart but can still get
drunk on new year's eve
side to him but i don't know who else i
don't know who else is out there
that has both those sides
well i would think that alex already
discussed who
he would love to see after i would have
assumed that these conversations have
happened
um but ideally i would like to see a few
personalities host jeopardy just kind of
changing it up and let the let the fans
decide
who would carry on the legacy i mean
that would be my preference i don't want
them to just pick someone and that's who
we're stuck with forever i mean
obviously the person's going to be
fantastic but
i still think that we should have some
sort of say this is our show just as
much as it is theirs
yeah i think it's tough you have to have
someone like you don't just want a
comedian kind of type like you need that
alex to practice like you said anderson
cooper i'm thinking of uh uh what's his
name
neil the astronomer the uh neil degrasse
tyson
the grass tyson like i can see that yeah
someone in that kind of realm like a
bill nye kind of type like i think you
need
an intelligent type of person that but
also has the hosting ability i think
that has to come first before the
hosting
comedian side of things come into it